all right look Morty Kojima just wants
us to reconnect the fractured society
and stop the  stranding what are
all these goats those are the
stranding rail okay yeah I wasn't paying
attention oh I we've been walking for a
while and I got this baby in a tube here
it's some sort of crazy upgrade hold on
I've got an idea
not an upgrade let's eat it we can't eat
it so baby what if it makes us run
faster jump higher okay let's eat the
baby yeah hey what's up guys what's up
guys and season 4 it's the forest of
all seasons
cuz it's the fourth one it's a lot
different from season three you've got a
lot of a lot of shoot-'em-ups a lot of
laser shoot-'em-ups and crystals little
monster I thought you were
you took that in stride there are old
faces coming back for a little bit more
of that old stuff that they did the
reason the you're getting five and then
a small break and then the back five is
because Turner Broadcasting warned us
about entertainment signal levels we had
all ten ready to go but we had to
legally cut it back to just five we did
some focused test screenings we showed
all ten episodes to a housewife from
Salt Lake City and her balls blew off
like after episode three it was just too
much we upped it by two episodes for the
skateboard crowd because they're more
extreme they drink Mountain Dew it's
really because if you watch them all
together in a row it's they're so good
it has a high effect on your deep
cellular tissue
Rick and Morty could actually literally
blow your balls off we missed all of our
deadlines you say you love
before season 4 premieres on November 10
the Rick and Morty binge a - thon next
Sunday from 9:00 p.m. to 5:00 a.m.
binge till the Sun comes up welcome back
everyone it's Charlie we have brand new
Rick and Morty season 4 footage to
breakdown they did a big stranding
crossover and they released descriptions
for all of the episodes for the first
half of the season
so I'll be doing Easter egg videos all
season long if you're brand new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get the
videos and I will do merch giveaways and
all my Rick and Morty videos all you
have to do to enter those is just be a
subscriber and leave your best season
for theory on the video just starting
with the Kojima stranding
crossover footage if you're not familiar
with stranding that's the game the
Kojima is releasing and actually I think
the next week if not the next couple of
days I love how quickly Morty turns
around on Rick's plan like no we have to
piece together these disparate pieces of
society left over after this giant
Cataclysm we have to keep this baby safe
well what if the baby gives us special
powers makes us run fast then not
wasting a minute okay let's totally eat
the baby there's also this one screen
grab that they posted to their Twitter
account saying that we're only allowed
to show you this and it's totally out of
context it's just Jerry
standing up to Rick and Rick looking
like he's really pissed off that he has
to take it it does sort of harken back
to what they said about the new dynamic
for season 4 which just like Beth
said at the end of season three is very
much like the season 1 season 2 dynamic
where he's the old grandpa that they
tolerate but they don't question the
fact that Morty goes on adventures with
him every week then there's all that
brand-new footage from the other promo
new footage of Professor poopy butthole
fighting his students off in the
classroom there's new footage of them
flying through this asteroid field then
this scene of the snake shooting the
other snake you probably recognize as a
parody of the first Terminator movie
which I guess makes Morty there Sarah
Connor this snake is wearing the exact
same shirt in jacket is Kyle Reese and
has the same ability to work a shotgun
just as well and this snake has the
cybernetic looking Terminator red eyes
like the t100 hard to tell which episode
this correlates to but then there's more
footage of the me
seeks scene for some reason Morty hits
the button on the me six box but Rick
yells added to Morty r.i.p Rivoli
o´clock burg then there's this new scene
of rick yelling at morty about stealing
crystals which they also reference
during this akira reference scene later
in the trailer looking like it gives
more days some sort of akira like
abilities this scene is just more of
them at that lush planet from the last
trailer then dan and justin both a joke
about why Adult Swim is only advertising
five episodes before the break everybody
is asking this and they're like what's
the deal with them only saying five
episodes he blames the break on lame
audience members in the Midwest like he
talks about mom's than the skateboard
crowd but really it's the exact same
thing they did during season one
breaking the season in half they aired
season one at the end of the year then
what happened is they went on break for
a couple weeks during the Christmas and
New Year's holiday then they came back
for the rest of the episodes the second
half of the season at the end of January
so they might just do the exact same
thing but Justin does confirm go on a
little break after the first five
episodes then come back so it's not like
there's only going to be 5 episodes
total they're supposed to be ten total
episodes in season 4 Justin makes fun
of them for blowing all their deadlines
but they are actually working on season
five episodes already while they're in
post-production on the last couple of
episodes for season 4 so don't worry
it's not like they're behind schedule or
anything like that that's just them
poking fun at themselves for how slow
they used to be there was also another
brand new clip that they dropped during
the Adult Swim development meeting
recently I can't post the complete clip
here but it was basically Morty getting
bit in outer space while they were
changing one of the tires on Rick's
spaceship in the dead of space Rick
tells Morty to be careful what could
possibly hurt us out here because
there's nothing around them then all of
a sudden this space snake that you see
dead on the dashboard just winds its way
up and bites Morty through his space
suit rick yells at him to get back in
the spaceship then you get the scene of
morty complaining about dying in rick
complaining about Morty's complaining
before they get back to the garage and
he tells him not to put too much of the
ointment on himself or he'll have to
hunt what he becomes which he then
totally does and rick just slowly pulls
his gun out everyone pull out your
voucher for one free replacement morty
the last promo is just a special rick
and morty marathon that Adult Swim is
running Sunday in honor of the season 4
episode 1 premiere so they might drop
some new footage in
middle of that if they do I'll totally
do a new Easter egg video for it but
recently they also just released
official descriptions of the first five
episodes all the ones that are airing
before the Christmas holiday because
technically season 4 is meant to be
ten episodes but they're just promoting
the first half of it before the big
holiday break some of these are real
gems and you'll see and they're listed
in order so it's season 4 episode 1
through episode 5 going down the list
edge of two more T rigged I repeat more
T goes nuts this time dog Ric does stuff
season 4 premiere bro the title edge of
tomorrow Ric diver Pete is a reference
to edge of tomorrow the Tom Cruise movie
based on the Japanese manga all you need
is it sounds like he or Rick or
both of them might wind up dying
repeatedly but the description only
mentions morty going crazy in this and
my earlier theory was is that it would
be the chachi episode of them running
from the aliens just because there's a
big alien threat in edge of tomorrow
season 4 episode 2 the old man in the
seat we all have one thing in common bro
I don't know bro watch this one
surprisingly unhelpful description but
the title is a reference to Ernest
Hemingway's the old man in the sea is
the story of an old man trying to catch
a giant fish in the battle that he has
with it since Rick spends so much of his
time in the promo though in that special
hover chair pretty safe bet that the
title is a reference to that in the
episode season 4 episode 3 one crew over
the crew coos Morty lots of twists and
turns this time bro wear your helmets
also a description that's not super
helpful but it might be related to the
Akira's situation reference that they
make during the trailer with morty
battling people behind the mall and then
summer and beth fighting each other on
that airport tarmac Captain America
Civil War style Claude hoarder special
ricktum Morty Morty gets a dragon in
this one bro it's a wild ride bro the
title is a reference to Law & Order
Special Victims Unit they confirm in the
description that this is the one where
Morty gets a dragon that Rick is talking
about during the trailer but it's kind
of hard to connect any of the other
trailer footage to what's going on
inside the living room here when they're
talking about the dragon Law & Order
Special Victims Unit is the show that
ice-t is on but I don't know if they
have any plans to bring back the water
tee character from get schwifty they
joked on the commentary about that about
how the story that they did in the
post-credits scene could have been their
new Game of Thrones like maybe we should
do some more with that with that
intergalactic war that they keep
referencing then season 4 episode 5
rattle star Ric lactic ax lots of things
happen in space bro snakes and sharp
stuff watch this bro the title of the
episode is a reference to Battlestar
Galactica but it also specifically
mentions space snakes in the description
so that's from this episode with the
dead space snake wearing the spacesuit
that had just bitten Morty if you
spotted any other big Easter eggs and
the trailers that I didn't mention in
the video just post them below in the
comments and Rick and Morty season 4
episode 1 will be releasing on November
12 so it's almost just a week away since
they post those episodes so late at
night
all my easter egg videos for the
episodes will post monday mornings as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see the videos
whenever I post them but leave all your
bonus video requests or if you have any
big questions you want me to include in
videos congratulations Sean pero you're
the giveaway winner from my last Rick
and Morty video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details every one click here for
that last pick Rick and Morty trailer
with all the fourth wall break scenes
and click here for my giant Rick & Morty
season 4 playlist thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome we'll
see you guys tonight